you know kind of hard
so it's actually
it's showing that she's striking
actually
that's kind of beside the point it's
basically
the rising strike here now often
is
so i like a bit more
uh
decisiveness in the movement because
we're going to intake we do something
called
the japanese or parts of the mountain
echo
so basically i throw this out
one of the purposes of this technique
did you vanish if you did it right
so
you know the one thing that saw me they
were gonna
flash in front of you and you've got if
you get
occasionally you will get this on the
map as it comes in to enter
it's like what the hell you can't
actually see him
you know he's somewhere because and then
this
because he's behind me i can't
do anything about flat i can't really
see
so you need to be right behind
is
like
all you've got to do you know it just
happens occasionally that's what it's
kind of full
so yeah so it comes in you'll make sure
you're going deep
okay
that's pretty good i can't see
this is not really good yeah
it's too vulnerable
all kinds of reason you know
it's a long wave yeah